entrer dans le bureau d'Omar Bongo
c'était ouvrir un livre d'histoire
sur les murs toute la Cinquième
République et un air de France Afrique
depuis sur son mur il avait trouvé de la
place pour Nicolas Sarkozy
Omar bongou avait une passion immodérée
pour la politique française au point dit
certains de la financée
un ex-président accuse à son tour Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing selon lui Omar Bongo a
contribué à la campagne de Jacques
Chirac en 80
la campagne de mon concurrent alors il y
a eu un temps mort que j'entends encore
et m'a dit ah vous le savez
ce qui était merveilleux médiocre
polémique rétor que Jacques Chirac et
ses proches de l'époque je ne l'ai
jamais vu distribué de l'argent en tous
les cas en ce qui me concerne ce n'était
pas mon cas je dirais simplement que sur
Giscard d'Estaing compte tenu des
fonctions qu'il a occupé ne peut pas
dire n'importe quoi sans en apporter les
preuves
prevenons la vieille querelle entre deux
vieux ennemis relance une vieille
affaire la France Afrique ou comment
conforter des régimes dans les anciennes
colonies pour mieux servir les intérêts
de la France
longtemps la France Afrique fut un
visage celui de Jacques Foucart
résistant gaullistes le Monsieur Afrique
du général c'est lui qui intronise au
marbongo un ancien des services secrets
français c'est lui qui fait du Gabon le
pivot de ses réseaux
je reconnais que les relations que je me
suis créé avec des commerçants européens
et par la suite des des chefs d'États
africains constituent un réseau
mais je n'appelle pas ça un réseau
ces réseaux vont perdurer d'année en
année à droite comme à gauche je
considère que les deux septunats de
François Mitterrand n'ont pas été
parfaitement claires sur le plan de la
France Afrique je considère comme
arbongo et d'autres chefs d'États
africains ont beaucoup aidé beaucoup de
dirigeants français et je crains que ces
dirigeants n'aient pas toujours
forcément été à droite
et aujourd'hui où on est on selon les
experts la France n'aurait plus ni les
moyens ni l'envie de jouer aux faiseur
de roi je pense que ici à Paris il y a
une normalisation une des relations
franco-africaines banalisation et le
président Nicolas Sarkozy offre n'hésite
pas à dire que la France a plus intérêt
aux proches et au Moyen-Orient en
Afrique une page serait donc tournée son
excellence et Ladj Omar Bongo emporte
ses nombreux secrets lui qui n’hésitait
pas à dédicacer ses livres ainsi la
force du silence est majeure en amitié
[Musique]